the whole point was I asked you for a
double standard that doesn't benefit
women outside of who he's sleeping
around okay so I get that yeah and the
the counter that I was offering is
because there is the weakness of a woman
so when she hits a man why it's not seen
as as impervious as a man hitting a
woman suppose that is the strength
questions
he looks way stronger than me right yeah
and I he would I get less time or more
time because he's stronger than me both
of you are men and you both stronger
than me it doesn't
okay
yes I'm weaker than him so is he going
to get more time because he no it's
going to be two black men and you're
gonna miss that but that's the point
that's the point we're trying to it's
not about strength I'm trying to say
that you've contradicted